being 10:00 we'll call the finance
committee meeting to order first on our
schedule today is a a hearing on House
Bill
1279 and we'll call on the prime sponsor
representative Mike Edgar
you good morning
representative morning Mr
chairman thanks for hearing this bill
today
everybody for the record that my name is
Mike Edgar I represent Hampton and in
the Hampshire
house
uh
say uh yeah thanks for letting me
introduce a bill today um I just trying
to say I think somebody you heard some
of this before tried to get this through
a few times appreciate you are listening
to it
again um more plainly this bill requires
the state to pay 7 and a half% of
political subdivision employer pension
contribution on behalf of teachers
police officers and
firefighters many of you know the
history of the state reneging on has
promised to fund a portion of of the
retirement system Others May testify in
more detail on the history uh but a few
of the low points are as follows 1967
the state encouraged political
subdivisions to join a Statewide
retirement system for teachers police
and firefighters and said it would
contribute
40% in 1977 State reduced its
contribution to
35% 2009 an amendment to uh reduce the
state share to 30% in physical year
2010 then was an amendment to reduce the
state share to 25% in physical year
2011 however in 2009 Amendment restored
the state contribution to 35% in
physical year
2012 but in 2011 amendment to completely
eliminate the state contribution to zero
yes
zero in 2022 HB
1417 for 75% restored passed the house
but Senate changed it to one year only I
know the towns and the schools
appreciated the one year they
got again town cities and schools were
asked to join the state retirement
system with the promise that the state
would help defay the employer costs when
the New Hampshire retirement system was
formed in
1967 replacing four smallest separate
Retirement Systems the state contributed
40% of the total employer costs the 75%
contribution
from 14 from hb1 1417 was for only one
year then it reverted back to
zero since the state R Gage promised the
political subdivisions have had to pay
for the state share of the employer cost
much of which has been downshifted to
Municipal and local school property tax
rates please pleas consider voting ought
to pass on HB 1279 to partially
reinstate the promise of the state to
the political
subdivisions it would be provide much
Rel relief to political subdivisions
that help offset the need for increased
property
taxes hb1 1279 helps the average
taxpayer in New
Hampshire uh thank you are there any
questions any questions for the
representative representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question is
House Bill 1279 identical to last year's
house bill
50 it's identical to the one that was
changed last year
yes followup follow up thank you um are
you aware that um the house position on
House Bill 50 is now in front of the
senate in the form of house bill
436 I know that the Senate does have a
house bill that's excuse me a bill that
is similar to the one that I had that
was changed
yes one more question thank you
um do you think it's productive to to
send the Senate sort of twice the the
same thing twice rather than uh you know
sort of make more work for them is that
more likely to get something passed or
or should we just leave it the way it is
I think you should pass this the way it
is it's not not the same as what they
the Senate has I
understand representative thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking my question uh first I just
wanted to applaud you for bringing this
forward again I know that at the end of
budget negotiations there was um
declarations from both sides of the
aisle that we would continue to work on
this this matter um and as you know the
end result was that uh our state donated
donated quite a bit of money towards the
tail of the retirement system Debt
Service um but I assume that this bill
does not
um I'm sorry I have not had a chance to
read through word for word but from my
memory the last time it was proposed
there was not a Debt Service um portion
to this bill it's just for The Upfront
Al a is that correct that's
correct
um I think that's it thank you Mr
chair anyone else from the committee
representative
Griffin uh House Bill 436 which was
similar to this I think uh is superior
to this bill in that by reducing the
unac
liabilities you earn money you earn more
investment money on the pension fund
which gives the
municipalities a uh a benefit each year
in the
future what's your viewpoint on
that the Viewpoint I guess would be is
that that the $50 million depend how
it's divided and set up and sent in is
uh you know it's nice to have to try to
reduce some of the liability that there
is in is in the system and if you were
going to do 50 million a year I think
that would really really contribute to
it but the towns and cities the ones
I've talked to say that this actually
helps them a lot this actually gets to
the towns and cities to do something
with versus um a one-time shot at at
providing some I think it's good I some
personally believe it should do both
but thank
you
anybody
else seeing none thank you
representative Edgar okay thank you very
much we have another um sponsor here
representative
Ms thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee um I for the
record uh my name is Chris muns um I am
also a uh representative from Hampton
and um I'm here to support my my system
was established in
1967 the legislature made a long-term
commitment to the cities towns and
school districts in New Hampshire that
in in in return for joining the
system the state would provide a
significant portion of the um annual
retirement
contributions um and as representative
Edgar mentioned that started at 40% and
um was that way for a number of years
and unfortunately was eliminated uh for
the 2012 fiscal year when the
contribution that represented probably
one of the largest tax increases ever
imposed on our towns cities and school
districts by the New Hampshire
legislature um it also imposed a
significant burden on
employees who were part of the
retirement system who um negotiated in
good faith uh wage and benefit
agreements
assuming um certain rates of um certain
uh rates that they would have to pay
into the retirement
system um I think it's in it's time for
the legislature to correct that that uh
unfortunate error um um particularly um
in a time when we do have uh some
significant financial
surpluses um and I would urge the
committee to recommend to the Full House
that this bill be passed um as presented
thank
you questions from committee
members are you aware that in the 2012
budget the majority of the difference in
the money that had been contributed by
the town taxpayers was actually
contributed by the
employees paying more than 2% or two and
a quarter or 2 and a half% more in their
contribution than they were prior so
that covered most of the cost it didn't
pass on that much to the municipalities
I don't know why that that false Rumor
Has
persisted well portion of the increase
still was absorbed by the communities
but your question um just confirms the
or Echoes the point that I made in my
testimony that um a large share of the
burden was imposed on the employees the
employees who are our teachers our First
Responders um and who who entered into
good faith bargaining agreements
assuming um that they would receive
these uh benefits um long
term representative hacken Phillips
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question uh
is it true that towns and municipalities
are currently planning for and proposing
their new budgets for the up coming
fiscal
year um it's far beyond proposing I mean
the the warrants have been written and
um yes those um are going to be uh put
to the voters uh in most cases in March
and a followup Mr J and um
representative is it also true that the
town's budgets are significantly
affected by the New Hampshire retirement
sister system contributions and that an
increase of state aid towards this
contribution would make it more likely
that the local property tax races rates
excuse me could be decreased or lessened
for
taxpayers absolutely thank you thank
you further questions from committee
members seeing none thank you
representative thank
you
I have a uh next person will be Deborah
how from Bo New
Hampshire thank you chairman wer members
of the finance committee my name is
Deborah H I am here representing the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire and our 3700 members across
the state and all of our retirees who
are in indeed members of the New
Hampshire retirement system and um I'm
here just to talk a little bit about um
the impact that the change in terms has
had on municipalities from a Workforce
standpoint um the increase that M
municipalities have had to pay for their
share of the retirement system has
become a drag on Workforce Recruitment
and Retention um it takes up an
increasing share of municipalities
budgets and it means that it is harder
for them
to raise wages to be competitive in the
current environment um it's hard for
them to keep up with Private Industry
there are
many public service jobs that are vacant
at this point and it makes it hard to
you know keep par Educators keep
teachers special education teachers in
particular uh jobs filled makes it hard
to keep Public Works jobs filled makes
it hard to keep the roads clear on snowy
days like today or the sideworks clear I
walk through slash to get here um
so going back to what was either
originally promised or even just
7.5% of the state contribution to the
retirement system which was made to
encourage municipalities to join the
retirement system would be a huge help
to local budgets it could allow easing
the burden on local property taxpayers
and could allow municipalities to uh
appropriately recognize their Workforce
and fill some of these many many empty
positions police fire Public Works and
indeed in the schools to provide the
services that our Granite State citizens
deserve I have written testimony they
all passed around and I apologize I
actually have to be over in house
education for a hearing that started 2
minutes ago but thank you for listening
and I appreciate your time this morning
questions for the for the witness seeing
none thank you very
much next we'll call on Adam denore from
The
Dr welcome to
finance thank you uh good morning my
name is Adam denor I'm the assistant
director of the municipal and property
division at Dr uh agency does not have a
position on this legislation but there
is one piece of information I wanted to
pass along uh when repayments like this
occur we incorporate that into our tax
rate setting process which is a quite
busy season which starts on October 1st
if there isn't a provision in this bill
to include a date that retirement
provides us with those figures ideally
that would be October 1st it can start
to affect tax rate setting um a couple
of years ago when these repayments were
made I think it took until close to the
middle of October for us to receive the
figures and so therefore a number of
cities and towns uh went without a tax
rate from for you know close to 30 days
because we needed to get those figures
to start the process so that's pretty
much all I wanted to pass along is that
it would be nice if there were a date in
there that we could receive these
numbers by to make sure that no tax rate
is
affected thank you sir questions from
committee
members so how much reduction in in the
property taxes was there this last year
with the contribution of the seven and a
half that's an excellent I can certainly
get the answer for that um hopefully but
I I do not know off top of my head about
as much as the 100 million that we put
in reduce to sweat it didn't seem to
make much
difference I I unfortunately I do not
know yeah thank
you all right and next we
have yes represent hack thank you Mr
chair um if I could just go back to your
testimony and um clarify you said you
needed a date to for the Dr to be able
to discharge like its rate setting yeah
could you could you give us like a
walkthrough of what you what the Dr
would prefer to see in terms of date
setting sure absolutely yeah there's a
number of pieces of information um
certainly Financial from the
municipality itself but also if they're
part of a Cooperative School District or
any number of other agreements that
require convergence of data for us to
set an accurate tax rate and one this
would be this repayment would be one of
those items um we begin tax rate setting
on October 1st and um so if we don't
have that information by October 1st it
it is inevitably going to delay rates so
is I'm sorry Mr chair may have a quick
call up um so is it correct to say that
um if the dates could be set prior to
September 30th of the year that they're
currently contemplating in this language
um would that be an appropriate deadline
to have that information set over to the
Dr absolutely okay thank you so
much further questions from committee
members seeing none now we will call
upon the head of the um retirement
system Marty
Carlin welcome to
finance uh thank you Mr chair u a bit of
a correction I am not the head I am the
director of communications and
legislative affairs the to get in front
of any skis um and for the record my
name is Marty Carlin nhrs does not have
a position on this bill as one of the
sponsors uh spoke to this is similar
language to that both has been
introduced in the House and Senate in
recent years this bill um would not
change the amount of money nhrs receives
um in total rather it would just have
the state be picking up a portion of
what normally would be p paid for by the
employer so there's no uh impact on the
unfunded liability there's a you know
the earlier Bill referred to house bill
50 was a one-time appropriation towards
the unfunded that would have been
recognized over 20 years and lowered um
the employer contribution rate so the
rate itself would have been lower uh by
some amount this is a basically you know
a subsidy for contributions for uh local
police teacher and fire costs um
as um the previous speaker indicated um
you know with in involving tax rates
that that's not how the reimbursement
traditionally worked there was a bill in
2022 that was a one time 75%
appropriation that at the time that was
about 26 million I believe and that was
after the fiscal year so in that case it
was the state was refunding the
proportion that the employers paid in
that prior fiscal year when when the um
State contribution was in effect you
know from
1977 through
20110 it we had a mechanism with the
state where we were you I think I'm not
sure what exactly the frequency was but
the employers weren't paying 100% they
were paying you know 70% and then we
were billing the state over the course
of the fiscal year and then reconciling
it at the end so this bill doesn't speak
to the mechanics so I think I think we
would want to work that out if this bill
were to pass with with uh the the
appropriate state agencies to see the
the the whole sort of mechanism both the
state and uh nhr has changed software
platform significantly since 2010 so we'
kind of have to reinvent the wheel but
that's how the process had traditionally
worked when this was an annual subsidy
the 2022 bill was a one time after the
fact payment so that there's a little
bit of a difference there be uh be glad
to answer any questions anyone has about
the
proposal questions from committee
members seeing none thank you sir thank
you and looking at the blue
sheet I guess we've heard from most of
these people Mike Edgar signed in and in
in favor Brian real I think it is um
pffnh signed in in favor uh Chris muns
we heard from him also signed in in
favor I only have the three names on the
blue sheet anyone in the audience that
wished to sign in and didn't all right
we will close the hearing
on House Bill
1279 and I believe it will be going to
division
one
few minute break before we start at
10:30 on House Bill
1323 making an appropriation for the
printing cost of New Hampshire state
constitution
okay
that's
so on on the last bill
1279 there were some people that U put
Communications
online uh Lisa gagalis from Northampton
supports um Senator Rebecca Perkins
quoka from Portsmouth supports Cindy
Rosenwald Senator Cindy Rosenwald for
Nashua supports and Julie Smith from
Nashua is opposed we'll put those in the
file thank you
all right it being 10:30 we'll open the
hearing on House Bill 13231 1323 and
call upon the prime sponsor
representative Hobson
welcome to
finance thank you very much this is my
first time here uh good morning
honorable colleagues my name is Deb
Hobson and I'm state representative from
district 14 out of Rockingham
County
uh in his essay The People's Liberty
honorable Dan itsa explains that to
discuss the nature of our Constitution
and the government it guarantees to the
people living in the state of New Hamp
is extremely important in fact part 1
article 38 States clearly that the
people are to go back and study the
Constitution frequently so as to be able
to force those in elected offices to
adhere to the Constitution quote a
frequent recurrence to the fundamental
principles of the Constitution begins
this article there is a misconception
that only lawyers are competent to
understand the Constitutions this
misconception has led to an abuse of of
the people under the guise of
constitutionality by the
Judiciary when considering the
Constitution we should consider that the
prim primary expository works on the
constitution for the United States of
America The Federalist Papers and the
Anti-Federalist papers were written as
newspaper articles for everyone to read
these writings themselves have been edit
edited even for the students of
law realize how much this controls the
understanding of interpret ation of the
Constitution however if one reads these
expository works then and then reads the
Constitution one realizes how simple and
straightforward the Constitution is they
simply wrote what they meant and except
for the changes in our
language no interpretation is necessary
and their definitions of the words are
obvious from the context the
Constitution of the United States is
even more straightforward than the con
I'm sorry the constitution for the state
State of New Hampshire is even more
straightforward than the Constitution of
the United
States that for our constitution was
meant for the average person to read and
comprehend is obvious from the
Constitution itself as a new state
representative my campaign centered
around fixing the problems in our state
when one takes the oath to uphold the
New Hampshire Constitution and the US
Constitution it's quite overwhelming to
be faced with 800 to a th000 pieces of
legislation the different stakeholders
information presented through the
hearing process challenges your
understanding that is when the New
Hampshire Constitution proves itself to
be a valuable guide since I've started
studying the New Hampshire Constitution
my favorite article can be found in part
1 article
38 my favorite uh local Constitution
expert calls it the voter guide uh so I
brought this forward um out of a
constituent request as well as um a
personal request I constantly visit the
the Secretary of State's office and ask
for copies of the Constitution and uh
quite frequently they have to go back
into the archives uh because the ones
that are printed for the current
Administration are saved for um the
fourth graders or the high schoolers and
and there's not enough for me to hand
out to my constituents so um uh this is
this is a request to increase the
funding I just simply doubled it um and
so I'm hoping that you will see uh OTP
this legislation thank you thank you
questions from the committee for
representive
Hobson representative tersi thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my
question I just wanted to I don't know
if I'm first when I read this I was a
little confused because it seems silent
on what they were for but you're saying
that they're for the Secretary of
State's office to distribute to the
public when
requested thank you for the question yes
uh when I um
I guess one of my constituents uh was
looking to uh pick up a box of
constitutions and um it was made clear
to her that there wasn't enough and so
that if we wanted to print more we would
need to put more money into the budget
so that's the reason for
this followup
followup this may be a question for the
secretary but um do you know the um the
primary um users of the existing um
constitutions and I only ask because I'm
wondering if online versions aren't
sufficient for um School
purposes
um the I I think everyone should have a
copy of it um everyone should read it
it's it's really a great document and
there's something different about having
a physical copy um it's it's easy to
read it's easy to reference I think that
people don't look at online resources
the way they would look at a a physical
book um but you can certainly probably
have more information from the Secretary
of State thank
you further questions from committee
members seeing none thank you representa
Hobson oh wait a minute represent hacken
Phillips thank you Mr chair I'll wave my
arms a little higher next time um I did
have a question about the um note the
fiscal note it says that the Department
of State indicates the bill appropriates
$155 per copy of the Constitution but
according to the most recent cost
estimates from June
2023 it actually cost $148 per copy and
I was just
wondering
um why the variance why why such an
increase so I'm not aware oh thank you
for the question and I'm not aware of
the fiscal note where that information
came from I actually got a copy of the
latest invoice that the secret Secretary
of State's office paid and that's what I
that's what I was using as a quick
followup Mr chair would you support uh
an amendment to this bill that lowers
the um total allocation according to the
actual per cost per
copy um once the bill goes to committee
it's yours to do with what you will and
I think the Secretary of State's office
has uh an amendment um that he'll be
talking
about
forther oh no I'm okay represent
Emme thank you Mr chairman are these the
the small uh copies that fit in your in
your purse or your pocket that are about
2 by three in no actually uh thank you
for the question and no actually I was
um interested in the larger I think it's
5 by seven okay um I think that's a
that's a more attractive easier to read
version but um that's just my personal
preference okay thank you so again it's
your your bill you can do with it what
you need to
string you um thank you for taking my
question and and for joining us today um
you indicated this is a doubling of the
budget um is that mean that we uh print
and and uh give out 10,000 copies of the
New Hampshire Constitution a year right
now thank you for the question right now
I think there are 5,000 that are printed
um and I'm not aware I think that there
is a statute that indicates high school
students should be receiving a copy of
the New Hampshire Constitution as well
as I know they give it out to the fourth
graders so in my in my uh estimation if
that's not enough for General members of
the public to come pick some up for
different events and things like that
then we probably should be printing a
lot more than 5,000
so that was where that number came
from in my discussions with
representative Hobson the fact that they
the first few pages are the governor the
speaker of this house senate president
and some of the other um
leaders those are photos that have to go
in there it adds to the cost and it adds
to the and the fact that it it expires
in two years so if we had just the text
like represent Emer said in like a 3in
by 6 in thing that you could fit in your
pocket um it would last for years
because the text doesn't change that
often and if it did then we' go through
the amendment process and we we would
have to replace it but to have some that
would last for a while on the Shelf
without being um outdated in two years
would would be a big Improvement and
then the secretary of state will tell us
how it can be funded and maybe the
format and we'll discuss that maybe in
the subcommittee but thank you
representative Hobson and so we will now
hear from the Secretary of State who
maintains this document and has it
published every two
years welcome secretary
scanland thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm David scanland
Secretary of State
uh and I support uh this
legislation uh I think it's always good
that we can make constitutions available
not only to the school children in the
state but any any New Hampshire citizen
um when we print these uh we print
enough for the school children and then
we have some left over which we
distribute to the general public when
they come into our office and ask for
them uh sometimes we get low on them and
we have to run up to the archives to
find uh volumes from past years uh that
are still
available this is uh this is what the
Constitution looks like uh that we
currently
provide we print these every two years
and we put them out to bid whenever we
do that which is a reflection of the
cost and and how that differs from bium
to
bium um what I would suggest is that uh
the chair of the committee asked me how
you know is there a way that we could
fund these and the short answer is yes I
believe that we can fund them from
within the department we have uh what's
called a notary fee account which is in
RSA uh 5 colon
10-b uh that account is uh is the result
of contributions a portion of the fee
for uh becoming a notary public or a
justice of the peace and out of that
fund we produce a manual uh for notaries
and
justices the Nexus is that the justices
of the peace are a
constitutional uh position and they are
listed in article two part 2 article 75
of the
Constitution and then when you look at
the stat statute uh that applies that's
actually mentioned in the proposed
legislation RSA 455 colon
17 uh it directs my office to print
these Publications from uh those funds
and any other educational materials that
are important to notaries and to make
these available to the general public so
that fund uh the notary fee account
which is in 510- B uh builds up uh and
we have a
surplus uh actually every year uh the
law says that when the banum is over we
maintain $100,000 in that account and
then anything above and beyond that is
uh uh lapses to the general fund so
there is money in that account to do
this I suggested printing up to 10,000
copies per uh bium so that we can manage
the inventory of those copies uh
obviously if you know we do an initial
Printing and the next bium we still have
5,000 left then we're not going to do
another 10,000 we're going to do
something less than
that
um yeah I think that's really all I need
to say I'm happy to answer any questions
I'm happy you bring this funding to us I
appreciate it very much so we don't have
to worry about where we going to get the
money from from I wonder if you're going
to change the format to leave out the
photos which should lower the cost and
and have it not expire would you
consider that I I certainly would
consider that I you know I'll leave that
direction to the legislature to let me
know what you would like to see
obviously for the school children you
know we would still do this version that
has the photos in it I would consider
this that that kind of a separate
account and this would be a new so if
you want if you want uh the
3x4 versions or if you want the larger
one without with or without photos uh
just let me know it was interesting when
years ago when my fourth grade class
came and I from my school not from my
fourth grade class that was a million
years ago but handed it out to each
student and I thought this is cool
they're going to each have a copy of
this so then I spoke to one of the
fourth grade kids and said so have you
got your Constitution at home so you can
study it he said no the teacher kept
them for next year's
class so you know we try we TR we try to
do some one thing right and and it
doesn't always last but that was the way
it went thank you very much appreciate
you bringing us the information
representative tersi I got a couple more
questions over here thank you for being
here today I have a quick question do
you feel the legislation's actually
needed or could your office just simply
print more Constitution since you
apparently have the funds
available I think the legisl legislation
is needed if we want to use this source
of of Revenue right now we print them uh
and the statutory requirement is for the
school children um and that the fund
that we use to print those I believe is
the same fund that we used to print the
red books the manuals for the general
court and I I believe we uh get an
appropriation of $220,000 a year uh for
that purpose um obviously printing a red
book is a lot more expensive than
printing the Constitutions but if we're
going to make the Constitutions more
broadly available uh
um I think it would help to have the
legislature say that we want to use the
funds in the notary account
uh to do that um because then the policy
position is clear thank
you representative grassy yeah there was
there was a comment that concerned me
from the previous speaker you're going
to have 10,000 copies but I think was
said was that if uh somebody wanted to
have an event and they wanted to come
and get a a box of them like I'm going
to have an event in Rochester I want a
thousand copies you're going to give me
a thousand copies you're going to run
out of them pretty
quick well we get those requests right
now and we ration them uh we try to make
them as available as available as we can
we also like to know what the event is
uh obviously if it's a campaign event
and you know giving constitutions to
potential voters is is problematic and I
think that we try and exercise some
discretion there but if it is more of a
if it is a more nonpartisan public event
where issuing the Constitutions is
educational then
yeah we would consider giving a thousand
copies for an event like that how I mean
how would you be able to Li I mean I
don't know how you'd be able limit I
mean whether it was a campaign event or
a a public event for educational
purposes I mean how do you how can you
do that I mean it's public
information well we we try to gauge
what's you know what they're being used
for um and if it's if it's clearly you
know partisan a partisan of that's going
to benefit you know a candidate let's
say then then we would uh you know we
would hold back on passing those out but
like I said if it if it was a more of a
public event nonpartisan educational
then yeah I think it's appropriate to
make them available but I mean that is a
good question and and it is an
issue okay I guess uh representative
Stringham is next and then
representative uh hacken Phillips and
then representative Heath then
representative Maguire so let's remember
that order I thought you had your hands
up no all right representative hacken
Phillips thank you Mr chair thank you um
Mr secretary for taking my question um
is it true that there are full copies of
the New Hampshire state constitution
available on the Secretary of State's
website or the general court website the
I know the Constitution is ready readily
available uh I'm not sure if it's on our
Secretary of State website but it
certainly is on nh.gov
uh and it it is readily available yeah
and just a quick followup Mr chair uh is
there any reason that you couldn't refer
uh these additional public requests to
just go to the website to get those
copies is opposed to you know providing
extra copies that are not mandated
through current law to CH school
children um is there any reason why you
just couldn't refer them to the website
there's no reason why we couldn't do
that
representa Heath thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr secretary taking my
question um in terms of this bill um any
requests that we have for you in terms
of how this document should be copied um
in the different formats would you like
to see that as an amendment to this
bill certainly any any specific guidance
along those lines that you want to
provide yeah we're we're happy
to honor all right thank you
representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question have you ever actually run out
in the sense that you couldn't there
were fourth graders that didn't get a
current one or there were PE members of
the general public who didn't get at
least an old
one we have run out of
some versions depending on on the bium
we always make sure that the school
children get them as soon as they're
printed we distribute those and then
it's the ones that are left over that we
keep in our office for the public to
come in and pick up um we have run out
of those uh and when that happens we go
to the archives where uh we have the in
inventory of Prior years stored and we
bring those in um you know
uh we I guess the short answer is yes
sometimes we run
out May so but the archives sounds like
it's an unlimited supply of constit I
mean is the archives going to run out at
some point no but you have to remember
that the versions of the Constitution do
change and so once you know once a a
change once the citizens of New
Hampshire vote on a constitutional
amendment uh during a general election
and they pass set then the old versions
are
are notated I understand thank
you and remember every one of us has a
copy in the black
book if we're wondering what's in the
Constitution it's right there in our
black
book further questions from
committee seeing none thank you thank
you very much for
coming on the blue sheet we do not have
any
signatures so this will go to division
two
and excuse me and you may
make well it it talks about
education all right division
one
ah all
right now we have a few minutes before
um we hear at
1560 and I will be
looking to have a
different
yeah
okay
time being 11
o'clock we will open the uh public
hearing on HB
1560 and the prime sponsor is
soon to make a
comment welcome Mr
chairman thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee previous budget this
committee um reduced the amount of money
coming out of the business taxes uh the
governor had sent us a budget with 35%
of the business taxes going to the uh
education trust fund at one point it was
50% but with the reduction in in uh
enrollment we didn't need that
much uh we we reduced it to 22% because
I was here when we did the original
education trust fund and we made up what
it covered and it was only to cover
adequacy nothing else it was just
intended to be adequacy everything else
building Aid special ed tuition
Transportation came out of general fund
it did that for years and I thought it
should be restored to what it originally
was so we did that in this committee
brought it down to 22% which just about
covered adequacy and a little bit more
we sent it off to the to the Senate and
they went from the 35% as originally
proposed by the governor to
44% which left this
huge $200 million in an education trust
fund when those of us that sat here and
and heard something about the uh
litigation on the sonunu youth center
realize they're over spending the 100
million that we did put in and they're
liable to have it spent in this next
this more than 100 million in this next
biennium so there are other places where
we will need this money and we will not
need an education because we've already
paid for that and we put it in the
budget for two years so this money would
just sit in a trust fund and not being
able to use for perhaps the highway fund
when we've added to the highway fund
general fund we've added to the Fish and
Game general fund because their
traditional um sources of revenue don't
cover them especially with people
getting 28 miles a gallon and driving
electric vehicles which are finally
going to pay something in this next year
so I don't want to have as as a finance
person I don't want to have this money
in a fund that can only be spent on
education when we need it in so many
other places so I bring this bill in to
try to re take that money that's
there at the end of of this fiscal year
and put it in the educa put it in the
general fund where we'll have more
flexible use of it if we needed it for
Education things we could use it we've
done that in the past we've always use
some general fund for the education uh
funding but to have an education trust
fund surplus of almost 200 million is
not in my estimation Good Financial
Management so I bring this bill before
us so that we can take that money and
move it to general fund thank
you questions committee yes thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr chair for taking my
question so you want to restore you
would like this legislation to restore
the education trust to its primary per
purpose of only only funding adequacy it
doesn't do that it just takes this
Surplus and puts it in general fund it
doesn't affect what's happened with that
that's for the next
budget so your your intent is not to
restore it toward its original
purpose we could do that ourselves
within the within the next budget that
would mean the education Freedom
accounts would no longer be in that
account perhaps not unless we decide to
do that in the next budget follow up M
follow up so in the education trust
currently we have building Aid we have
special ed we have court ordered
placements that it's like an open
warrant because we don't know what the
cost will be we also have a new um uh
section this time and I'm going to
forget uh it's what is it situational um
episodic episodic um yep placements um
and the costs with that we don't even
know what they're going to be yet so as
we look at the trust as it stands right
now there are
multiple amounts of money that are
targeted in that
fund where in the general fund are we
going to put all these other
funds we have in the past uh virtually
funded all of them from the general fund
so the place as Financial managers we
have to have funds that we have
flexibility so they've always been
funded when we had extra people sign up
for any one of these programs we found
the money in the general fund and and
traditionally those are always funded in
the general fund follow up
though thank you thank you for taking my
another
question just formally being at the the
department of Ed um and those other
costs like used to be catastrophic Aid
um those funds were never fully
funded and when the amounts were
intended to be divied out to school
districts more times than not the
reduction ended up being in the
percentage that went out to local school
districts to reimburse them for the
costs and in some years it could be as
low as 65% of the original
costs when we have a an account that we
have a general idea of what we're going
to spend it just seems to make so much
sense to in fact have them in a
consistent line item additionally what
about the lottery this is the lottery
sends a lot of money to the trust and it
just to me or or I should phrase it as a
question don't you think it makes more
sense publicity wise and for the State
of New Hampshire when we see the ads on
TV about the lottery giving so much
money to the education trust doesn't it
seem more to make more sense to keep the
education trust sound and with funds
available for the costs that they will
incur over the cost of the bium as I've
said we've taken the money out of
general fund when we needed it for
education purposes but if we have it's
like the highway fund what if the
highway fund had a surplus and I
remember it did years ago and one
Governor wanted to have a holiday on the
on the um Highway fund so that he he
felt he could make it up with
tourism and we turned that down the
numbers didn't make
sense a specific fund like education
trust fund had a a single purpose in
mind and yes we have used the excesses
for other places and yes there was a
time when it was a decision by the
Department of Education we put so much
money in and I remember doing the budget
and we do it how much should we increase
the education trust how much should we
increase special ed well here's how much
we spent last year how much should we
add for next year we were going up 12% a
year our 12% a budget that's you know 6%
a year what what is going on with
special ed are any of these schools
trying to keep it lower no so so there
were some years when everybody went a
little bit crazy and just kept spending
and spending on special ed and what
happened was the department of Ed scaled
it down and said okay you got so many
requests we can't fulfill them all
everybody's going to get a reduced
amount and even if there had been more
money in the education trust fund it
would have taken an act and a law to
move the money so you know that was that
was a decision by the department of Ed
those few years when we didn't fully
fund the requests because we couldn't
imagine they'd go up 20% a year or 20%
over over a budget who could have who
could imagined that you don't know what
to do when you have huge increases like
that and to try to say well we went up
we went up 10% last time let's go up 12%
this time and it still wasn't enough
yes thank
you
so if in fact you transferred this money
back to the general
fund wouldn't it mean that at the end of
the
banum really this money would end up
going into the rainy day fund
yes question it wouldn't now is it's to
stay in the education trust
fund yes thank you Mr chair and thank
you U Mr chair for taking my question um
maybe um because you were around at the
origination of the education trust fund
you can help me understand it was my it
was my understanding that the original
order from the New Hampshire Supreme
Court directed our state to create the
education trust fund for the purposes of
protecting State funds to be spent only
on educational needs is that correct
correct
so isn't it I'm sorry just a quick
followup go ahead you're on a roll isn't
it also true then that with the recent
New Hampshire Supreme Court rulings
directing us as state legislator
legislators to increase educational
spending wouldn't that order be at risk
if we decided to empty the education
trust fund at the end of the year were
those funds would then lapse into the
rainy day fund my question is how is it
not at risk well at the end of the
budget time whatever Surplus goes into
the goes into the rainy day fund and
whether but when you say it's education
trust fund you can't put it in there so
you carry that on to the next budget I
would
suppose and you know but that would mean
that other things that we might need
more
of we would not be able to fund we need
the flexibility we're the ones that do
the financing and the budget we need
flexibility we could still take money
out of the general fund and spend it for
whatever was needed if there was some
extraordinary cost in the uh education
side that wouldn't prevent us we've
always spent General funds for special
ed for tuition and transportation
building Aid all those came out of
General funds forever and I've been
doing this since
99 so you know to say oh yeah we can't
do that because it's not in there and
even in the case where we didn't fully
cover the um special ed they could have
come back to the legislature if they
were a bill to put it in and said can
you give us more money in special ed
that would have been the way to do it
rather than say okay you're only getting
65% or whatever the percent they they
got that was a possibility to do but it
still would have taken some legislation
even if there were money in the
education trust fund to get that money
you would still need an appropriation
and we would have to be
involved
Peter thanks Mr chairman thanks Mr
chairman for taking my question instead
of just emptying the entire education
fund would you be ad meable to say less
$50 million so there'd be at least $50
million in there instead of just taking
all the money out I would hate to make
it a Target that everybody oh I've got
an idea to spend that 50
million if there's a if there's a real
need that competes with all the other
needs they will get the money that's the
most important thing that's the decision
that Finance committees make and sell it
to the rest of the legislature but to
have the money tied up where it ties our
hands for other purposes I'm opposed to
it as a person that's supposed to manage
Finance it's not a good process okay
thanks
Dan thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my
question don't we already have a a
companion piece to this which says that
if the education spending needs are ever
greater than what's in the education
trust fund that it's automatically
backfilled from the general fund well
we've been doing that all these years
and it would again it would take some
legislation to do it I don't think it's
an
automatic may I follow I believe it is
in law that that that happens all right
um and I'd like to if I may have a
followup so um to to representative
Heath point about um the lottery in
particular so we have a constitutional
requirement that Lottery money always
goes to education always
and so some might say well you've you've
co-mingled Lottery money and now maybe
some Lottery money is going back to the
general fund via this mechanism so
shouldn't we to make this
clear add a little something somewhere
else that says when we spend adequate
education we first use all lottery money
right and then fill it with other money
from the education trust fund therefore
there's there would be nothing left in
the education trust fund that was yeah I
I disagree that anything is comingled
because it's already gone into the
education trust fund everything from the
lottery that is Surplus obviously if the
lottery brings in a a billion
dollars
600,000 7 700,000 goes to
prizes so yeah we can hear about how
much it brings in but most of that goes
to prizes and then a little bit goes to
Administration everything else goes to
the education trust fund so the way you
would look at it as an accountant how
much did the uh Lottery bring in let's
say it's 100 million how much did you
spend on education let's say it's 500
600 million okay you've spent the money
already you can't argue that some it's
co-mingled in this
Surplus thank
you I think you said the same
thing any other questions from the
committee yes ma'am thank you Mr Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um I think we are all well aware of the
um court cases that revolve around
school funding and I think we are all um
probably understanding that there will
be some major significant changes when
it comes to um how we determine school
funding would you not agree with me that
it may be prudent to take such a large
decision such as this and um either make
that a part of the uh the larger work in
the education subcommittee on school
funding or at least wait until we know
um what the future holds in the coming
year or two I went to the expert that we
all use for Education funding sitting
right
here and I asked Mickey if we took
everything we spent on education and
divided it by per pupil how much will
we'd be spending in 24 and 25 and it
came out if I recall it was like
7200 7300 so the figure that the judge
came up with interestingly enough we are
already spending if we contribute
everything that we put on education and
divide it by per pupil yes we're already
spending that so that's my defense for
this this decision by the judge we've
already done that so to say oh we need
to spend hundreds of millions more no we
don't we've already done it if we take
proper credit for everything we spent on
education and divided by the total
number of students that's what we get
and I sent that to the attorney general
after after Mickey sent it to me
hopefully he's used it but anyway that
was that was my decision when I heard
that oh you should spend 7,000 per pupil
not 4500 or whatever figure was we
did and I'm surprised they didn't use it
in the defense but it's there if we have
to use it thank you Mary thank you one
final
question with regard to special
education
do you realize that local property
taxpayers pay in excess to almost
$900 million yearly for costs related to
children with disabilities at the local
level I know we have a formula that they
have to spend three and a half times the
average cost per pupil before they can
ask for Aid then they then they get an a
match 80% from the state 20% from the
town until it reaches 10 times the
average cost per pupil then all the
costs above that are paid for by the
state follow
up do you know how often those costs are
fully paid back to local
municipalities from the Department of
Education I do not thank you
other questions from the
committee Dan thank you Mr chairman so
um with regard to the rainy day fund
issue that representative walner bro
brought up don't we really in in our
budget control and and anticipate what
we put into the rainy day fund because
for example in this past budget we spent
a lot of 2023 money on on ual things
that we wanted you know we we we we
spent we knew a surplus was coming sort
of and we spent part part of that on it
actual items uh and so thereby we
controlled what would would actually go
into the rainy day
fund yes that's why we took out of swept
hundred
million to help reduce property taxes
and this 26 million that we took for the
7.5% onetime payment for retirement
match so there was 126
million that went in the 2023 taxes that
wasn't there before how much did it save
us in taxes my bet my tax bill went
up so these people that that come in and
tell us we've got to have this money we
got to have this money to save taxes it
doesn't the schools will use up every
penny that's where 85% of my taxes go
and typically they'll come out with a
school report you have 28 fewer students
this year we've hired 18 new
people when you have people that don't
have
any real grasp of trying to be
efficient this is what we end up with
thank you other questions from the
committee thank you Mr
chairman yes
sing just in terms of the uh the
analysis um the 72 to
$7,300 that include did that include the
base payments plus special ad plus
everything else that the state puts in
all the money that the state put into
education
things uh School
construction
teachers uh
retirement
um all those things tuition and trans
portation special
ed all those things if we total them all
together and divided it by the total
number of students it came out to the
7200 7,300 per student which how could
you say that isn't a per capita or a per
student cost or what we've
spent thank you follow follow isn't the
things out of the coming out of the
courts now mainly addressing just what
the base amount is not
adding on uh the other things I don't
think they said base amount I think the
the language I read is you don't spend
enough per
pupil and after I added up everything or
had Mickey add up everything that's what
it came out to so that's how much we
spent you can't say that this that the
uh education funding was funding for
anything but pupils and their
education
any other questions with the
committee thank you Mr chairman thank
you we have one pink card Mr Brian
Hawkins from Nea
NH uh thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record Brian Hawkins uh representing NAA
New Hampshire we represent over 177,000
uh Public School Educators in the state
um um here in opposition to the bill
also I wanted to make sure that you all
didn't get to lunch too early because uh
apparently I'm the only other speaker
here so that's the other purpose I'm
here today um uh first off I I would say
um it's a lot of the points that I was
going to make in my testimony came up
for questioning um so uh I'll just uh
follow up on a few of those first um
there's no doubt that there are a lot of
needs the state has um
that this was uh mentioned earlier I
think that's exactly a reason not to um
move forward with this piece of
legislation because this would move this
These funds into the Gen into the
general fund um where there are uh this
committee knows there are a great number
of needs um not only in in education but
in Health and Human Services uh Public
Safety um one of the areas that uh I
think we've face in education but in
other Workforce in in other areas is the
workforce shortage and so the state's
ability to fund um uh an adequate
education and and the aid that comes
from the state that's critical for a lot
of school districts to be able to
compete with those communities that have
an easier time raising the funds needed
when we are under such a a a a Workforce
shortage and
um not only are we competing with other
states for uh teachers and support staff
we're competing among communities and so
uh we already went through the usages of
the education trust fund the other uh
points I would just raise again the
unknowns that we Face uh the LA the
lawsuit was mentioned um also the EFA
program the EFA program U has already
exceeded um budget amounts um in every
year that it has uh been there there are
several bills normally I would be down
the hall in House Education there are
four bills alone there that would expand
uh eligibility for that program and so
um again another unknown um Beyond just
uh the
lawsuit
uh the last point I think I I I would
just make is that we feel that these
funds belong in uh public education and
uh they should remain there and we hope
that you'll find this bill um in
expedient to legislate happy to take any
questions thank
you anyone from the committee have a
question for Mr HW
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my
question why is it that there are so
much funds in the education trust fund
is it possibly
because um at one time
there there were many more school
children than we have today and and so a
larger percentage of business taxes Etc
were needed for Education than they are
today with Excuse me with the with the
per pupil spending um relatively static
and until uh recently uh I think that's
a part of it I also think that you know
we are in very good Economic Times and
so the uh so there is a robust Surplus
in um General funds uh maybe less so
this year but General funds and in uh
education trust fund and with those
obligations
that are out there and those unknowns I
think it would be pretty mature to just
say that uh These funds ought to uh go
back into the mix with other other
funds follow
yeah thank you thank you uh Brian for
taking my question um with the Advent of
Charter Public Charter Schools um we've
I think we've got somewhere in the
vicinity of um about four or 5,000
students that are currently attending
charter schools and of those children um
there's a percentage of those children
um who have
disabilities and because our statutes
state that
the uh sending School District Remains
the school of liability for those
services do you have any idea what the
costs are for those particular students
currently um to the local
municipality for the any idea what that
would be um I have heard this brought up
a number of times um I don't have the
exact figure before me but I think it
does bring up an important I listed a
couple of unknowns in education um this
committee is well aware that the uh
State of New Hampshire accepted a $46
million Grant from the federal
government to expand uh existing and uh
new uh public charter schools um and
that Grant we I believe several years
into that Grant I go to State Board of
Education meetings regularly and so I I
see the uh approval for expansion of
seats in existing and and new Charters
um that you know that is also an unknown
to to the the degree to which uh and
this is not to say positive or negative
about the grant or Charters is just that
uh with that significant amount of money
dedicated to
expanding um the legislature obviously
also didn't increase this past uh budget
for uh not only uh uh traditional but
also Public Charter School uh state aid
um that's another unknown that uh
presents itself and why it ought to be
uh why we think it's premature to to
take this action
now question thank you thank you Mr
Hawkins for taking my question I don't
expect you to be um an expert on the
lawsuits that have been filed however
since we were discussing with the prime
sponsor um my question about if this is
um getting ahead of ourselves and we
should perhaps wait do you know we were
talking about the um average cost per
student Statewide but the um the amount
that the um the judge stated as his
suggested Baseline around that's base
adequacy so anything beyond that such as
special ed or any English language
Learners anything like that that would
make that amount go higher is that
correct in my understanding that's my
understanding yes thank
you other
questions thank you Mr Hawkins thank you
enjoy your launch we have uh on the blue
sheet we have one opposed and that is Mr
Hawkins okay no if there no other
comments this will close
the question thank you Mr chair Mr chair
I just wondered would we be able to get
the document that Mickey prepared for
you that you shared with the attorney
general
yes okay great that'll be helpful thank
you
okay I'm hesitant here everybody has
something else to say go ahead Dan yeah
this is in the nature of an announcement
I guess um so people were talking about
um the the conval and other lawsuits I
have a constitutional amendment being
heard Wednesday at 9:00 in judiciary if
anyone is interested that's relevant to
those
topics sound like a sales pitch to me
okay no with no other business we'll
close the hearing on 1560 and we're done
for the the full Finance is done for the
day I know division two is meeting at 1
o'